Monsoor posh teen is the face of a
growing protest movement in Pakistan one
daring to challenge the country's
powerful military and earlier this week
officials arrested him on conspiracy and
sedition charges Pashtun has accused
security forces of widespread abuse
against the ethnic Pashtun minority
under the pretext of its war on terror
his group has accused the military of
extrajudicial killings and thousands of
disappearances he says that as the Army
has battled Islamist militants it has
unfairly targeted Pashtun zin the
country's Northwest in just the two
years of his activism Pashtun has seen
his movement grow across the country the
military has imposed a strict media
blackout on the group but their peaceful
protests still draw tens of thousands of
people I'm joined in the studio by Omar
Ali of dwu social media service and also
dwu correspondent shot Zeb Jelani shot
Zeb let's start with you
who is Mansoor Pashtun and why is his
message gaining ground
Mellisa most people in Pakistan had
never heard of one Zul pristine until
about two years ago it's a fascinating
story how he's now suddenly a household
name in Pakistan he somebody was born in
the tribal region of South Waziristan
it's a border region along Afghanistan
he's the son of a schoolteacher he was
studying veterinary science in school
and he grew up during the so-called war
on terror he witnessed a lot of bombing
and killings and brutality around him
and eventually his own family was forced
to move out of the tribal areas so he
has seen all this firsthand and when he
holds rallies across Pakistan where tens
of thousands of young people come he
speaks from his heart from his personal
experience and that's why his message
resonates with a lot of people the
Pakistani army however sees him as a
foreign funded agent they call him a
traitor they seem as somebody who's
acting on behalf of external forces
namely Afghanistan now there are many
opposition
oops why do you think the military is
particularly threatened by him well many
people who criticize the military or its
alleged abusers in Balochistan province
in Pakistan's other areas they they come
from different ethnic groups the reason
man superstein is seen as a bigger
threat is because he belongs to a
Pashtun ethnic identity
now the Pakistani army is mostly
comprised of people from Punjab soldiers
are mainly recruited from the biggest
province of Punjab and the second
biggest ethnic group are the push stones
and there's a fear that Mansour posh
teens message is resonating with Pashtun
officers and soldiers within the armed
forces so it becomes a case of sort of
divided loyalties and so the Pakistani
army wants to ensure that this doesn't
carry on and they will do whatever they
can to stop him well shut serve was just
talking about the message being spread
umer I'm curious if there is a media
blackout against reporting on this
movement how is the message spreading
yeah it is true indeed that there has
been a media blackout and you can't
really cover or talk about PTM the
movement by module 15 on on local media
unless unless it is taking cues from the
military and and and sort of I would say
repeating the talking points of the
establishment but but as you said they
have built a huge following both on the
ground and on social media and I think
it's partly due to their use of social
media apps like Twitter and Facebook I
have been following them for the last
two years you ever since they began and
they have been using social media to
call for protests across Pakistan and
across across the world and they have
been live-streaming
their you know their protests and at
times their protests have been watched
by thousands of people what have you
been seeing over the last few days since
his arrest so it's very interesting and
I'll show you this one tweet by a local
journalist in Karachi who was covering a
PTM protest he wrote that smartphone has
become a prime tool of rights activists
in Pakistan
make their voice being heard over 30
activists are live-streaming the protest
and this was a protest of about a few
hundred people we talk about censorship
has anyone commented about censorship
and the fact that this movement isn't
being reported on yeah I think
unfortunately for the I think for the
large part a lot of a lot of TV channels
are not even trying to cover them
anymore but there was there is this one
TV presenter who explained why the last
segment of her TV program was dropped
earlier this week she wrote on Twitter
saying because I reported on more st.
hours arrest more scene is one of the
Parliamentarians
linked with PTM and she wrote that she
asked on what charges was he arrested
but it was censored and she wrote
welcome to censor East on where people
must suffer in silence
well up till now this state has seemed
unsure of how to deal with Monzer posh
teen he emphasizes peaceful
demonstration and upholding the
Constitution here's an excerpt from a
speech he gave last year in Lahore to
the people who call us traitors the
Constitution of Pakistan shows who is a
real traitor article 19 in Pakistan's
Constitution says that the people have
freedom of speech article 6 of
Pakistan's Constitution clearly says
anyone who sabotages the Constitution is
a traitor how many times have these
generals sabotage this Constitution shut
up
so is he correctly quoting the
Constitution there and if so do the
charges of hate speech and Sedition
against him hold any water well most
people don't think so basically he's
calling for accountability of powerful
people in the Pakistani army people who
are allegedly involved in ordering
killings and abductions and committing
torture and abuses and it says it is a
machine it has been seen before in
Pakistan at any one whether they are
politician writers journalists activists
when they call for that accountability
they are in turn
accused of being a traitor and they are
then put in jail
GW correspondent shots at Jelani and DW
social media editor Umar Ali
thanks to you both